so wir kommen an diesem ersten Tag der
Haushaltsberatung in dieser Woche zum
letzten Einzelplan das wird der Etat des
Bundesministeriums für Umwelt
Naturschutz nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz sein das wiederum ist
so mit der kleinste Etat was zumindest
die Ausgaben anbelangt den wir in der
Haushaltssystematik haben im Vergleich
zu 2022 gibt es einen kleinen Aufschlag
insgesamt sind das für diesen Einzelplan
2,45 Milliarden Euro der weitaus größte
Posten der geht in die zwischen- und
Endlagerung radioaktiver Abfälle dafür
sind 1,16 Milliarden Euro eingeplant
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst auch
von meiner Fraktion gute Besserung an
die Bundesministerin
sie hat ja lange darauf verwiesen dass
man in so kurzer Zeit keine großen
Veränderungen im umweltetat vornehmen
kann und den Haushalt der letzten
unionsgeführten Regierung deshalb
fortgeführt bei jeglichen Fehlern der
Ampel nun auf die Regierungszeit der
Union zu überweisen ist inzwischen aber
nicht mehr als eine Platte die Liebe
ampelkollektion fatale Fehler und
falsche Entscheidungen wurden nicht in
den letzten 16 Jahren sondern in den
Wochen und Monaten nach dem
24.02.2022 gemacht Stichwort
Energiesicherheit Inflation und Atom
Debatte
so ist es auch im Einzelplan 16 um es
mit den Worten aus dem Fußball zu sagen
die aufgabenzeit für Bundesministerin
Lemke ist vorbei sie bewegt sich in
Richtung Halbzeitpause und hatte noch
keine klare und zwingende Aktion vor dem
Tor meine Damen und Herren so gewinnt
man kein Spiel
der uns nun vorliegende Haushaltsentwurf
2023 für das für den Einzelplan 16 ist
zumindest ein kleiner Lichtblick denn im
Gegensatz zu wenig ambitionierten ersten
Regierungsentwurf haben die
ampelfraktionen fast alle unsere Anträge
während der Haushaltsberatung mit
eigenen Anträgen übernommen das hätten
sie auch einfacher haben können immerhin
haben sie damit aber eingestanden dass
wir als CDU CSU Bundestagsfraktion gute
und wirkungsvolle
Oppositionsarbeit leisten
keine transparente Arbeit leistet das
bmuv beim Klima und transformationsfonds
des Bundes und bei der internationalen
klimainitiative eine teilweise Titel
Bewirtschaftung aus einem anderen
Einzelplan seitens des bmuv insbesondere
in einer Größenordnung von zusammen fast
900 Millionen Euro halte ich für sehr
kritisch diese Form der Mittel
Bewirtschaftung verstößt gegen die
Grundsätze von haushaltswahrheit und
Klarheit
leider ist das von der Bundesministerin
Lemke angekündigte transparente Vorgehen
bisher nicht festzustellen eine
Konkretisierung was für die oder was für
das mit dem Geld in einzelnen Lauge
gemacht werden soll und wofür es
gebraucht wird und verwendet werden soll
ist daher dringend erforderlich
ein großes Problem haben wir beim
nationalen Meere Schutz insbesondere bei
der Munition lassen in Nord- und Ostsee
gesehen im Koalitionsvertrag der
ampelfraktion wurde groß und
medienwirksam angekündigt für die
Bergung und Vernichtung von Munition
lassen in der Nord- und Ostsee ein
Sofortprogramm aufzulegen so wie eine
länderfond für die Mittel und
langfristige Werbung einzurichten und
solide zu finanzieren warum im ersten
Regierungsentwurf nur 22 Millionen Euro
für den nationalen Meeresschutz
vorgesehen waren obwohl so eine mobile
Plattform zur Bergung dieser Munition
mindestens 100 Millionen Euro kostet ist
mir bis heute unerklärlich unserem gegen
finanzierten Antrag des diesen Betrag
bereits im Jahr 2023 in den
Bundeshaushalt einzustellen damit die
Bergung der Munition schnellstmöglich
stattfinden kann wurde
dauerleiterweise nicht zugestimmt
immerhin ist man unsere einschätzen
gefolgt und hat die Gelder für die
Folgejahre vorgesehen jetzt darf einfach
nicht nur mehr bei Lippenbekenntnissen
bleiben jetzt muss gehandelt werden aber
nicht nur die Rüstungs Altlasten im Meer
stellen eine Gefahr für die Umwelt da
auch die rostenden Bomben an Land sind
eine Gefahr für den Boden und auch für
unser Grundwasser
hierbei jedes mal zu behaupten es seien
umweltetat an der falschen Stelle im
Haushalt verortet da ist sich lediglich
um Gefahrenabwehr handelt greift hier
viel zu kurz wie behandelt Position oder
wir erklären sie sich dass der Bund ohne
vorher Absprache mit den dafür
zuständigen Ländern Gelder für die
emotions-
aber im nationalen Bodenschutz nicht die
Gefahr für die Umwelt und letztlich
aufgrund Menschen ist in beiden
Bereichen immens
unserem Antrag 18 Millionen Euro für den
Bodenschutz bereitzustellen ist ein
Anfang um gemeinsam mit den Ländern
schnell und effektiv tätig werden zu
können
für
Verwunderung sorgt bei mir die Kürzung
der Förderung von Maßnahmen zur
Anpassung an den klimaverwandel und
knapp 15 Millionen Euro verstärkt
zunehmende Wetter Extreme sind in der
Bundesrepublik bereits spürbar und
stellen Menschen und Natur und
Infrastruktur für große Erfolge
Herausforderungen daher haben wir
beantragt diese Mittel zumindestens auf
dem Niveau von 22 zu belassen
Entschuldigung
dass wir als Union aber einen solchen
Antrag stellen mussten um eine Kürzung
von 15 Millionen zu verhindern
zeigt aber auch die schlechte
Prioritätensetzung dieser Regierung um
im umweltetat immerhin folgte der
Haushaltsausschuss unseren ansehnen sind
und hat dann einen eigenen Antrag
gestellt und diesen Mittelansatz dann
sozusagen verstetigt bei der Vernetzung
von Moorböden im Rahmen der nationalen
rollstuhlstrategie bin ich auf Seiten
des Ministeriums und viele die
Vorgehensweise richtig dass die
Landwirte als Nutzer der Flächen
finanzielle Anreize geboten werden
freiwilligkeiten Kooperationen sind
hierbei allerdings die Stichworte unsere
Landwirte brauchen für Ihren Betrieb
eine dauerhafte wirtschaftliche
Perspektive und Planungssicherheit das
Prinzip der Freiwilligkeit muss zum
Maßstab aller Maßnahmen zur Umsetzung
der Strategie gemacht werden und auch
bleiben beim Koalitionspartner im Grünen
bin ich da allerdings ein Stück weit an
Löffeln frau Präsidentin komme zum
Schluss unsere Landwirte brauchen wir
schon gesagt Planungssicherheit
eine geplante wiedervermessung wird
nicht nur einzelne landwirtschaftliche
Flächen betreffen sondern ganze Bereiche
Dörfer und ländliche Regionen und das
will wohl durchdacht sein und wir hätten
da gerne in Kürze auch mal etwas Näheres
aus dem Ministerium vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für unsere Auftakt dieser zweiten Lesung
des Einzelplans er ist wirklich im
Haushaltsausschuss und dort
Berichterstatter für diesen einzelplanen
die berichterstatt hat das sind ja
diejenigen die in den
haushaltsbereinigungssitzung noch mal
wirklich alles durchgehen jeden
einzelnen Posten und jeden Titel und er
hat es auch angesprochen es gab
Veränderung in der Bereinigung Sitzung
der Haushaltsausschuss hat
beispielsweise den Ansatz für den
nationalen Meeresschutz von 22 auf 30
Millionen angehoben um eben munitions-
und Ostsee zu beseitigen
Sebastian Schäfer jetzt für die Grünen
erst ebenfalls Berichterstatter für
diesen Einzelplan
ich verstehe das in der Union der
Phantomschmerz groß ist wenn man wenn
man nicht mehr regiert aber
entscheidend
bei ihrem fußballbild entscheidend ist
was das Parlament aus dem Entwurf der
Regierung macht ja und darüber reden wir
heute und nicht und nicht mehr über den
Entwurf
und wir haben diesen Entwurf im
Haushaltsverfahren noch mal deutlich
verbessert wir haben einen besonderen
Schwerpunkt beim Meeres und Naturschutz
gelegt hier übernehmen wir
entschieden mehr Verantwortung so können
wir das Sofortprogramm Munition lassen
jetzt mit 100 Millionen Euro
ausfinanzieren wir stellen die Summe
vollständig zur Verfügung die wir für
dieses weltweit einzigartige
Pilotprojekt brauchen
wir ermöglichen mit einer schwimmenden
verbrennungsplattform die sichere
Vernichtung von tonnenweise Munition die
vor unseren Küsten liegt dass es wichtig
für die marinen Ökosysteme den Tourismus
die Sicherheit der Schifffahrt und von
offshore-projekten und der Zeitplan ist
sehr konkret ziel ist es die Verträge in
2023 abzuschließen die Regierung hat
gerade in der Nordsee gezeigt wie
schnell Bauvorhaben fertiggestellt
werden können wenn der politische Wille
da ist und dass wenn wir jetzt auch bei
Meeresschutz unterstreichen
insgesamt werden die Mittel für den
Naturschutz deutlich erhöht und auch für
den bisher sträflich vernachlässigten
natürlichen Klimaschutz wenn erhebliche
Mittel zur Verfügung gestellt
sie haben auch die Anpassung an den
Klimawandel angesprochen und die
Formulierung ist ja ein echter
Euphemismus denn an manche Wetterextreme
die durch die Krise beim Klima viel
häufiger auftreten kann man sich nicht
anpassen wir brauchen aber zwingend eine
widerstandsfähigere Infrastruktur und
das Ministerium bereitet hierzu ja auch
ein Gesetz vor je nach Region hat der
Klimawandel sehr unterschiedliche
Auswirkungen wir sehen dass es in
Deutschland an vielen Orten Hitze und
Dürre immer stärker zunehmen nicht nur
bei mir daheim in Stuttgart der Kessel
war es in diesem Sommer oft unerträglich
heiß gerade der
ältere Teil unserer Gesellschaft leidet
darunter massiv wir haben in diesem
Hitze Sommer
4.500 hitzetote zu beklagen in unserem
Land und das in einer Klimazone die
eigentlich als gemäßigt gilt und der
Bund stellt jetzt noch mal Mittel zu
Verfügung um in einem sinnvollen Rahmen
für die Region diese Organisation und
Umsetzung durch Kommunen und soziale
Einrichtungen zu sorgen ein ganz
wichtiges Problem
wir haben im
parlamentarischen Verfahren auch auf die
das Fischsterben an der Oder reagiert
mit große Umweltkatastrophe die diesen
Sommer geprägt hat wir werden dafür
sorgen dass im bundesnaturschutzfonds
hier ein Förderschwerpunkt auf die
Renaturierung der oder gelegt werden
kann und können damit die wasserökologie
deutlich resilienter machen
die Ampel setzt Schwerpunkte dar wo sie
notwendig sind und die Ampel spart da wo
es möglich ist so setzen wir mit dem
Haushaltsgesetz eine pauschale
Stellenstreichung von 1,6% um eine
deutliche Erhöhung im Vergleich zu
Vergangenheit wie immer sind davon die
Sicherheitsbehörden ausgenommen die
Bundespolizei oder der Zoll jetzt nehmen
wir davon auch die Bundesnetzagentur des
Umweltbundesamt und das Bundesamt für
Naturschutz aus die Energienetze des
Klima die Natur das ist systemrelevant
das ist kritische Infrastruktur die
überlebensnotwendig ist
und so entsteht ein Bundeshaushalt auf
der Höhe der Zeit herzlichen Dank
Schäfer war das für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen und ihm folgt jetzt hier
für die afd-fraktion der Abgeordnete
Wolfgang wiele er ist Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss und ebenfalls
Berichterstatter für diesen Einzelplan
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen grüne Politik
muss man sich leisten können sie hilft
zwar manchen dabei sich als besonders
gute Menschen zu fühlen aber sie führt
zugleich zu wirtschaftlichem Rückschritt
gerade die Energiepolitik der Fraktion
der Ministerin liefert das beste
Beispiel dafür der Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie den ihre Ideologie befiehlt
verschärft den Mangel im Stromnetz
[Applaus]
zugleich verbaut er den Weg in die
Zukunft neue sichere Reaktoren der
vierten Generation könnten Reststoffe
für die Stromerzeugung nutzen die das
Ministerium Lemke und das Ministerium
könnte sich bei der mühsamen Suche nach
einem Endlager viel Arbeitsspeicher
durch ihre ausstiegspolitik steigt auch
der Strompreis immer höher der von
Deutschland gehaltene schändliche
Weltrekord in dieser Disziplin nähert
sich einem Durchschnitt von 60 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde
als Ersatz wollen sie große Teile
unseres Landes mit Windrädern zu
pflastern diese Motoren Schaden den
Menschen die in ihrer Nähe leben müssen
und sie führen zum Tod von Millionen
Vögeln und Insekten
als Lösung dafür haben sie zwar den
Menschen nichts zu bieten aber immerhin
gibt es in Ihrem Haushalt nun für die
Tiere 14 Millionen Euro für ein
sogenanntes
artenhilfsprogramm kein einziges Tier
Adler keine Eule keine Fledermaus wird
davon aber wieder lebendig dieses
Programm ist mit Verlaub nicht viel mehr
als ein Ablasshandel
so können sich viele grüne trotz der
gewaltigen Naturzerstörung durch die
Windindustrie offenbar immer noch gut
fühlen
das Bundesumweltministerium müsste an
der Spitze der Bewegung stehen die hier
lautstark Einspruch erhebt
wir von der AFD Deutschland und seine
Naturschönheiten wirklich liebt würde
eine solche Barbarei niemals zulassen
[Applaus]
kleine wünschenswerte Verbesserungen am
umweltetat können den Gesamteindruck
kaum verbessern das ist mehr Geld geben
wird um munitions Altlasten im Meer zu
beseitigen begrüßt die afd-fraktion
ausdrücklich wir unterstützen auch die
Forderung nach einem ergänzenden
bodenschutzprogramm
dass die Zuschüsse für die Anpassung an
den Klimawandel nun doch nicht gekürzt
werden sorgt für einen Funken Realität
sind dennoch wird die Realität
reagierungspolitik im ganzen von der
völlig abgehobenen Vorstellung geleitet
dass Deutschland mit selbstkasteigung
das Weltklima retten könnte
die mit geradezu manischer
Entschlossenheit betriebene Energiewende
leitet sich aus dieser Vorstellung ab
sie ist ein mächtiger Antreiber der
stärksten Inflation seit Jahrzehnten und
auch das beweist die grüne Politik sorgt
für wirtschaftlichen Rückschritt
sie zwingen damit auch viele Bürger
gerade dazu für das Heizen auf den
nachwachsenden Rohstoff Holz
zurückzugreifen ich wiederhole an dieser
Stelle die Aufforderung an die Regierung
die Bürger über das richtige Heizen mit
Holz zu informieren aber mit Schikanen
gegen Holzfeuerung endlich aufzuhören
ja
grüne Politik müsste man sich leisten
können die Beispiele zeigen wie diese
Politik aber in die völlig falsche
Richtung führt die afd-fraktion wird
diesen Haushalt ablehnen denn wir kennen
klar Deutschland kann sich eine solche
Politik nicht leisten
[Applaus]
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Michael Tews
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Kolleginnen und
Kollegen den Klimawandel und das
Artensterben zu stoppen sind zwar der
größten Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
Herausforderungen die so grundlegend
sind dass wir ihn nur mit einer
nachhaltigen Veränderungen in unserer
Lebensweise einer nachhaltigen
Veränderung bei der Produktion und bei
der Energieversorgung begegnen können
nach Berechnung des weltressourcenrates
der Vereinten Nationen sind rund die
Hälfte der globalen Treibhausemissionen
sowie 90 Prozent des
biodiversitätsverlustes und der
Wasserknappheit auf die Gewinnung und
Verarbeitung von Ressourcen für Dinge
die wir tagtäglich nutzen zurückzuführen
der Verbrauch von primäressosen wie
metallherzen Öl Kohle und Gas Holz und
Wasser müssen wir deutlich reduzieren
denn sonst zerstören wir lebenswichtige
Naturlandschaften
eine Kreislaufwirtschaft in allen
Bereichen im Großen und im kleinen muss
das Ziel sein wir können es uns nicht
leisten immer mehr Ökosysteme zu
zerstören oder zu beschädigen denn wir
brauchen sie im Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel aber auch im Kampf gegen
Artensterben Naturschutz ist Klimaschutz
Kreislaufwirtschaft ist Klimaschutz und
deswegen ist diese Haushalt von
besonderer Bedeutung
meine Berichterstatter Kollegen
Sebastian Schäfer und Frank Schaeffler
und ich haben jetzt gut elf Wochen über
den Regierungsentwurf für den Haushalt
des Umweltministeriums diskutiert wir
müssen auch immer bei diesen
Diskussionen mit Schutz der Arten der
Biodiversität des Klimas und der Natur
ging wir haben verhandelt wir haben
übrigens nie gestritten finde ich auch
noch mal wichtig an dieser Stelle dass
wir betonen haben verschiedene Optionen
überlegt und ein Fachleuten gesprochen
und uns schließlich für diesen wie ich
finde guten Entwurf geeinigt
bei den Projekten die der SPD von Anfang
an wichtig waren konnten wir zu einer
guten Einigung finden dafür möchte ich
mich auch bei meinen Kollegen noch mal
herzlich bedanken
so haben wir für rund 44 Millionen Euro
mehr für die Bergung der
munitions-atlasten aus Nord und Ostsee
begehen mit rund 100 Millionen für die
wir gekämpft haben werden wir das jetzt
ermöglichen
1,6 Millionen Tonnen gefährliche
Munition liegen auf dem Meeresgrund sie
stellen eine potenzielle und leider zum
Teil auch schon akute Gefahr für Mensch
und Natur da die wir so schnell wie
möglich in den Griff bekommen müssen
wir können jetzt mit dem Bau einer
schwimmenden mobilen Plattform beginnen
auf der Munition geborgen und schadlos
entsorgt werden kann und mit dieser
Technik werden wir gleichzeitig
Vorreiter in der Welt und können diese
Plattform und diese Technik vermutlich
auch exportieren denn leider werden sie
auch in anderen Teilen der Welt benötigt
viele Erkenntnisse hat auch die
Veranstaltung mit vielen Experten der
Kollegin Bettina Hagedorn in Haffkrug
gebracht an der ich teilnehmen durfte
vielen Dank für diesen wichtigen
Austausch
ich bin nun zuversichtlich dass wir im
nächsten Jahr schon eine konkrete
Zeitplanung haben und Ende 2023 die
notwendigen Verträge von technischen
Umsetzung der Bergung geschlossen sein
werden
denn Deutschland über wenig Einkommen
verfügt steht momentan wegen der hohen
Preise aufgrund der Pandemie und das
russischen angriffskriegs auf der
Ukraine besonders unter Druck und
braucht gegebenenfalls unabhängige
Beratung auf unsere Initiative hin
konnten wir das Fördervolumen für die
Stärkung von verschuldeten
VerbraucherInnen um insgesamt 4
Millionen Euro für die nächsten Jahre
aufstocken schon jetzt gelten rund 7
Millionen VerbraucherInnen als
überschuldet deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir auch von bundesweite und stärker
damit beschäftigen wir konnten erreichen
dass zusätzlich Mittel für die
Weiterentwicklung der
Verbraucherforschung bereitgestellt
werden kann die
verbraucherperspektive der Schutz der
VerbraucherInnen muss in dieser
Gesellschaft stärker berücksichtigt
werden Verbraucher Forschung muss die
eng begleiten
viele Änderungen haben wir auch für die
Naturschutz erreicht hier geht es nicht
mehr nur um Geld der
bundesnaturschutzfonds mit rund 244
Millionen für die nächsten Jahre
zufriedenstellend ausgestattet unsere
Änderungen bewirken hoffentlich dass
diese Gelder noch sinnvoller eingesetzt
werden können als bisher wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass in bestimmten Programmen
die in diesem Titel untergebracht werden
wie zum Beispiel bei der Förderung zur
Renaturierung der Auen und dem
Bundesprogramm biologische Vielfalt der
Eigenmittelanteil für die antragstelle
auf 10% herabgesetzt wird außerdem wird
der Antrag einfacher gestaltet der zu
hohe Eigenanteil und die oftmals zu
komplexen komplexen
Antragsvoraussetzungen haben mit dazu
geführt dass die Gelder für den
Antragsteller nicht beanspruch genommen
werden konnten und deshalb zum Teil
große Reste im Haushalt verblieben wir
haben Gespräche mit den Antragstellern
geführt und ich gehe davon aus dass die
Änderungen dazu beitragen können
dass diese Gelder jetzt tatsächlich in
die dringend notwendigen Maßnahmen für
den Naturschutz eingesetzt werden
mit dem Aktionsprogramm natürlicher
Klimaschutz werden wir den Klimaschutz
in den kommunalen Gebieten im ländlichen
Raum besonders voranbringen
natürlicher Klimaschutz bedeutet unsere
wälderauen Gewässer mehrere Grünflächen
Böden zu renaturieren zu stabilisieren
und zu schützen denn dieser leider oft
vernachlässigten Ökosysteme sind ein
wichtiger Faktor beim Klimaschutz bei
der Klimaanpassung und bei dem Schutz
der Biodiversität
gesunde und stabile Ökosysteme können
den Atmosphären vorhanden des
kohlendioxid-
wir stellen 100 Millionen Euro für die
Jahre 2022 bis 2026 für den natürlichen
Klimaschutz besonders in kommunalen
Gebieten im ländlichen Raum zur
Verfügung die Förderrichtlinie sollen
auch in diesem Jahr kommen und der
förderaufruf Anfang nächsten Jahres
gestartet werden ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass wir durch dieses Programm
und diese Gelder Verbesserungen für den
Klimaschutz die Klimaanpassung den
Schutz der Arten und die Lebensqualität
in unseren Kommunen schaffen und das
natürlich genau das was mit den Geldern
im Einzelplan 16 auch erreichen wollen
meine Damen und Herren ist die Aufgabe
von uns Parlamentarier und im
Haushaltsausschuss und die
Haushaltsentwürfe der Regierung genau
anzusehen und dort womöglich notwendig
miteinander für bessere Lösungen zu
kämpfen ich bin der festen Überzeugung
dass wir heute einen guten Entwurf für
den Haushalt des Ministeriums für Umwelt
und Verbraucherschutz verabschieden in
diesem Sinne vielen Dank
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen einen
schönen Abend schönen guten Abend von
meiner Seite auch an die Besucherinnen
und Besucher auf der Tribüne wir führen
die Debatte fort und die nächste
Rednerin ist für die Fraktion DIE LINKE
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist es gut dass
der Etat im Bereich Unwetter Naturschutz
erhöht wurde es gibt doch einige gute
Vorhaben zum Beispiel reparieren statt
wegwerfen mehr Recycling das ist sehr
vernünftig in anderen Bereichen sieht es
aber leider düster aus zum Beispiel beim
Verbraucherschutz hier gibt es immer
noch viel zu wenig Mittel und das geht
so nicht Kolleginnen und Kollegen
VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher die sind
zunehmend Unland mit unlauteren
Geschäftspraktiken konfrontiert der
Berufsinformationen der wird immer
größer kaum einer Blick da noch durch
gerade im Internet ständig soll man
Cookies Daten Tracking seitenweise
Allgemeine Geschäftsbedingungen
akzeptieren was man da akzeptiert
versteht fast niemanden Unternehmen die
nutzen das immer wieder aus um die Leute
über den Tisch zu ziehen
Verbraucherinformationen die müssen kurz
allgemein verständlich und leicht
zugänglich sein aber das Gegenteil ist
leider die Regel und die Ampel glaubt
ernsthaft diesem wachsenden Problem mit
gerade mal 100.000 € mehr
Verbraucherforschung Einhalt gebieten zu
können ja wie soll das denn gehen klar
ist doch nur wer wenn alle ihre Rechte
kennen dann gibt es überhaupt die Chance
auf ein faires Gleichgewicht zwischen
Verbraucher und Unternehmensinteressen
und genau das muss doch das Ziel sein
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
seine Rechte zu kennen ist das eine die
durchzusetzen ist das andere und dazu
braucht man gute Beratung und starke
Partner zum Beispiel die
Verbraucherzentralen ihre
MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeiter die Prüfung
Strom und Heizkostenabrechnung Decken
und lautere Geschäftspraktiken auf
beraten und begleiten die Verbraucher in
allen Belangen sie leisten hervorragende
Arbeit und ich frage mich warum machen
sie es diesen Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeitern nach wie vor so schwer ihre
wichtige Aufgabe zu erfüllen warum
starten Sie die Verbraucherzentrale
nicht endlich mit den nötigen Mitteln
aus das muss doch endlich sein denn der
Bedarf der ist riesig allein im
Energiebereich die Beschwerden zu
Stromrechnung haben sich in diesem Jahr
verdreifacht bei Gas sogar sieben Mal
mehr Beschwerden in diesem Jahr denn ja
es gibt Energieanbieter die sich mit
unlauteren Methoden an der Krise weiter
bereichern wollen da werden
unrechtmäßige Kündigung ausgesprochen
die Kunden werden in teurere Neuverträge
gequatscht oder genötigt oder man
schlägt einfach direkt mal noch einen
Zuschlag auf die ohnehin schon viel zu
hohen Preise drauf und jemand Menschen
davor geschützt werden braucht es mehr
Personal in der Verbraucherzentrale so
ist es nun mal und ihre Antwort ist
gerade mal zwei Millionen Euro mehr als
vor der Energiekrise bekommt die
Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband das
Doppelte wäre nötig die
Verbraucherzentrale fordert das zu Recht
und was sie hier fordert übrigens gerade
mal so viel wie ein halber Leopard 2
Panzer kostet nur mal so zum Vergleich
man könnte den Eindruck gewinnen sie
wollen gar nicht dass die
VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher zu ihrem
Recht kommen und auch hier habe ich ein
Beispiel im nächsten Jahr kommt endlich
die verbraucherverbandsklage sie würde
es Verbänden ermöglichen stellvertreten
für eine Vielzahl von Geschädigten
Klagen zu führen und die Geschädigten
werden dann auch direkt entschädigt zum
Beispiel wenn Verbraucherzentrale eine
gegen eine Bank klagt die überhöhte
Kontogebühren erhoben hat dann muss man
nach entsprechendem Urteil die Bank muss
direkt zu hohen Gebühren an die Kunden
zurückzahlen und sie wissen ganz genau
dass diese wirklich sinnvolle neue Klage
Möglichkeit richtig viel bringen könnte
dass die bloß ein Papiertiger bleibt
wenn die Verbraucherzentrale nicht genug
Leute haben um diese Klagen auch führen
zu können so bleibt eben Betrug und
Abzocke weiterhin Tür und Tor geöffnet
und das geht so nicht Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und was auch nicht geht
ist dass sie die vielen Menschen weiter
im Regen stehen lassen den jetzt
Überschuldung droht aufgrund der heute
so hohen Lebenshaltungskosten sind eben
nicht mal bereit hier das mindest so zu
tun was notwendig wäre nämlich das Recht
auf kompetente und schnelle
Schuldnerberatung zu realisieren die
Schuldnerberatungsstellen die sind
weiter unterfinanziert und deshalb
überlastet wenn wir da auf Auskunft
möchte der muss auf Monat lang auf einen
Termin warten oft ist es dann zu spät
das geht so nicht wir wissen wir wissen
Frau Kolleginnen jetzt ist leider so wir
wissen dass eine Welle von Überschuldung
auf uns zu holt experten rechnen damit
das sind 2023 fast jeder fünfte Haushalt
Zahlungsschwierigkeiten haben wird jeder
fünfte Haushalt und wir als LINKE haben
ausgerechnet was ist bräuchte für
flächendeckende kostenlose schnelle
schulterberatung ist bräuchte 25
Millionen Euro aber sie erhöhen den
Titan gerade mal um einen halben Leopard
2 Panzer und 2 Millionen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das reicht nicht dass in
Tropfen auf heiße Steine ist ein
Frechheit und vor diesem Hintergrund
möchte ich auch noch einmal sagen finde
ich es wirklich unerträglich dass Sie
unseren Antrag zum Verbot von Strom und
gassperren abgelehnt haben es droht
Hunderttausenden Haushalten in diesem
Winter eine kalte Zeit und Dunkelheit in
der Wohnung und ich werde nicht müde
dass hier zu sagen es wäre ihre Pflicht
es ist ihre Pflicht das zu verhindern es
reicht eben nicht sich immer nur
hinzustellen und wir never walk alone zu
sagen man muss auch danach handeln und
das wäre wirklich das allermöse
verbieten sie Strom und gasperren danke
schön
fordert für die Linke deren
Fraktionsvorsitzende Amira Mohammed Ali
hier in der Aussprache ja aufgestockt es
gibt noch ein bisschen Aufstockung
sozusagen für die Mittel im
Verbraucherschutz in der
Bereinigungssitzung des das
Haushaltsausschusses und zwar geht es
darum Maßnahmen zu resilienzfer und
überschuldeter VerbraucherInnen da
wurden die Mittel in diesem Titel noch
mal von einem auf 2 Millionen
aufgestockt aber Amira Mohammed Ali hat
ja gesagt 25 Millionen nach Berechnung
der Linken für die Schuldnerberatung
würde man benötigen ampult jetzt am
Rednerpult Frank Scheffler für die FDP
ja eine große ökologische Katastrophe
ist wenn Tausende von Tonnen munitions
Altlasten der Nord- und Ostsee vor sich
hin rosten
sondern ist natürlich auch eine große
ökonomische Herausforderung denn die
Meere werden ja auch genutzt um Energie
jetzt zu erzeugen Windkraftanlagen zu
errichten und so weiter sehschifffahrt
findet statt das heißt es ist auch eine
Gefahr für unseren Wirtschaftsstandort
und deshalb ist es richtig dass wir
mit diesem Haushaltsentwurf ja erstmalig
die Grundlage wirklich schaffen dass
etwas passiert wir hatten ja vorher
schon einen
Haushaltstitel geschaffen der hat uns
aber nicht ermöglicht das zu machen was
wir jetzt tun nämlich dass diese
schwimmende Plattform auch tatsächlich
ausgeschrieben werden kann denn dafür
war die Voraussetzung dass wir auch die
notwendigen
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen
bereitgestellt haben von 72 Millionen
Euro und jetzt sind wir in der Lage
dieses Thema auch wirklich anzugehen und
damit das auch
jetzt wirklich funktioniert und auch das
Ministerium entsprechend tätig wird
haben wir das noch unterlegt mit einem
maßgabebeschluss und haben das
Ministerium aufgefordert bis zum 30.06
entsprechend hier tätig zu werden und
diese
diese Anlage auszuschreiben das ist aber
nur die eine Seite die andere Seite ist
die Ausschreibung
führt ja noch nicht automatisch dazu
dass dann alles andere auch geregelt
wird man muss ja auch fragen wer
betreibt diese Anlage was passiert
eigentlich im Verlauf wie wer trägt
dafür die Kosten und da meine ich darf
man die Länder nicht völlig aus der
Verantwortung entlassen natürlich ist
der Bund außerhalb der zwölf Meilen Zone
verantwortlich aber innerhalb der
zwölfmal sind die Länder erstmal
verantwortlich und deshalb meine ich
muss es auch Verhandlungen mit den
Ländern geben was sie Kostenbeteiligung
an der Stelle betrifft denn die Länder
stehen
finanziell besser da als der Bund und
deshalb müssen die Länder hier an der
Stelle auch tätig werden und deshalb
Herr Kollege Feiler ist es eigentlich
auch ein falscher move zu sagen
das machen wir jetzt am Land auch ja wir
haben es ja als Bund ja der Unterschied
ist der Unterschied ist doch natürlich
gibt es ein Teil da habe ich doch gerade
erklärt der Unterschied ist dass genau
ja und außerhalb der zwölfmalen Zone ist
der Bund zuständig das ist der
Unterschied und in auf auf auf
Landesebene ist es eben eine klassische
Aufgabe der Bundesländer dieses Thema
für sich zu bewältigen und da können die
doch tätig werden ich glaube nicht dass
das eine Aufgabe ist in die der Bund in
eine Mischfinanzierung zusätzlich
hineingehen soll dafür gibt es dafür
gibt es keine rechtliche Grundlage und
wir sollten aufpassen dass wir nicht
immer mehr Aufgaben auf Bundesebene im
Rahmen einer Mischfinanzierung
finanzieren sondern das ist eine
klassische Aufgabe die die Länder
vollziehen sollen ich will sagen dass
wir als FDP
in diesem Haushalt
auch die blockchain-forschung im
umweltetat etabliert haben weil wir
glauben dass die Gefahren gut Abwicklung
auch sehr gut mit der
blockchain-technologie verbunden werden
kann wenn es darum geht
die Gefahren gut Abwicklung
rückzuverfolgen auch dauerhaft
rückzuverfolgen und sie vor allem auch
über Smart contracts automatisch zu
einem Bezahlvorgang führen kann ich
glaube das ist etwas wo sich auch die
Ministerien in diesem Haushalt aktiver
mit beschäftigen sollten denn das wird
am Ende Bürokratie abbauen und
gleichzeitig auch für mehr
Rechtssicherheit auf beiden Seiten
beitragen abschließend möchte ich noch
sagen dass es entscheidend ist
wenn wir über das was wir gerade schon
diskutiert haben das Thema
Energieversorgung und Deutschland
sprechen dass wir auch auf der
Angebotsseite auch stärker wieder
darüber diskutieren müssen dass wir
fossile Energien durch Kernkraftwerke
ersetzen ich glaube das ist etwas was
auch der Umwelt zusätzlich dient wenn
wir unsere drei Kernkraftwerke
weiterlaufen lassen würden dann könnten
wir alleine in Deutschland 5,2 Millionen
Tonnen CO2 einsparen würden wir die
würden die würden wir die drei bereits
abgeschalteten wieder ans Netz nehmen da
könnten wir auf 10,4 Millionen Tonnen
CO2 einsparen und ich glaube das sollten
wir auch tun aus Umweltgründen wir
sollten es aber auch tun aus Energie
Sicherheitsgründen denn Strom den
Stromausfälle können wir als
unintelligible Norddeutschland uns nicht
leisten und deshalb sollten wir alles
dafür tun dass wir das Stromangebot
insgesamt erweitern insgesamt ist es ein
zustimmungsfähiger Altar ich bedanke
mich für die Aufmerksamkeit vielen Dank
und für die CDU CSU hat das Wort Steffen
Bilger
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen diese Haushaltsdebatte
bald ein Jahr nach Antritt dieser
Bundesregierung bietet ja auch
Gelegenheit eine Bewertung vorzunehmen
der Arbeit der Bundesumweltministerin
und der Ampelkoalition im Bereich der
Umweltpolitik
und viele Regierungsmitglieder sind ja
zur Welt Klimakonferenz gereist und
haben anschließend das unzureichende
Ergebnis beklagt und das auch völlig zu
recht und ich will Anknüpfen an das was
Kollege Scheffler gerade gesagt hat denn
wir müssen ja einfach auch zur Kenntnis
nehmen dass die Glaubwürdigkeit
Deutschlands beim Klimaschutz leidet
wenn diese Bundesregierung lieber Kohle
verfeuert als klimaneutrale
Kernkraftwerke vorübergehend
weiterlaufen lassen
und da helfen dann auch weder die
moralisch aufgeladenen Appelle die man
da vereinzelt aus der Bundesregierung
gehört haben an die ganze Welt gerichtet
noch hilft sie frühere greenpeace-chefin
einzubürgern zur Staatssekretärin zu
machen zu Welt Klimakonferenz zu
schicken für die Bundesregierung wenn
die Bundesregierung gleichzeitig zu
Hause so unglaubwürdig handelt meine
Damen und Herren
was könnte was müsste die Rolle
Deutschlands beim weltweiten Klimaschutz
sein natürlich Antreiber auch Geldgeber
für ärmere Länder und nicht zuletzt
Vorbild für andere aber sind wir das
nicht wirklich und dabei geht es nicht
nur um die Frage der Kernkraft neue
züchtungstechnologien zur Sicherung der
globalen Ernährung synthetische
Kraftstoffe für emissionsfreie Mobilität
wasserstoffstrategie zum Erhalt des
Industriestandorts unter Wahrung der
Klimaziele CO2 Abschaltung und
Speicherung Zurückführung der Emissionen
planungsbeschleunigung überall hier
bremst vor allem die
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke und das ist
schlecht für unsere Zukunft
ich glaube wenn Deutschland glaubhafter
Vorreiter für einen
technologiegetriebenen Klimaschutz wäre
dann bekäme der globale klimaprozess
eine ganz neue Dynamik
Friedrich Merz hat am Wochenende darauf
hingewiesen dass die klare Mehrheit der
jungen Menschen sagt Innovation statt
Verbote um das Klima zu schützen
daraufhin
empörte Reaktionen aus dem linken Lager
passt zu ihren Zwischenrufen bis hin zum
Minister Lauterbach der vom angeblichen
ewigen Wappen auf Innovation getwittert
hat dabei sind doch viele Innovationen
schon da wir müssen die nur endlich
konsequent nutzen und nicht so behindern
wie sieht es mit ihren
Bundesumweltministerium tun
wenn Deutschland derzeit etwas dringend
braucht dann ist es eine offensive für
mehr Innovation und für Investitionen in
moderne Technologie statt für
Zukunftstechnologien einzutreten
verzettelt sich diese Regierung im Hier
und Jetzt voll zu Lasten der Verbraucher
ich zitiere das bisherige
Krisenmanagement diese Bundesregierung
überzeugt nicht so bringt es die Chefin
des Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverbandes
Ramona Popp auf den Punkt ich ziehe
weiter die gaspreisbremse kommen viel zu
spät dabei brauchen die Verbraucher die
Entlastung kurzfristig
so viel von Frau Popp von Ministerin
Lemke hören wir zu alldem als
Verbraucherschutzministerin aber kein
Wort
und deswegen wissen wir knapp ein Jahr
nach Regierungsbildung der
verbraucherschutzzeit im
Umweltministerium eine schlechte neue
Heimat gefunden
uns kommt aber noch schlimmer anstatt
aktiv für eine Entlastung der
Verbraucher zu kämpfen trägt das
Bundesumweltministerium zu einer
weiteren Verunsicherung der Verbraucher
und zu hören Belastung bei und ich will
noch mal das Thema Kernkraft ansprechen
mit ihrer Entscheidung für eine viel zu
kurze Verlängerung der Laufzeiten sorgen
sie aus reinen parteitaktischen Gründen
wegen ihren ganzen Jürgen Trittins bei
den Grünen und so weiter dafür dass die
Stromkosten 13 Prozent höher sind als
sie sein können deshalb Studien ergeben
13 Prozent höhere Stromkosten ohne die
Laufzeitverlängerung das heißt wer
tausend Euro Stromrechnung hat kann sich
für 130 Euro bei Ihnen bedanken das sind
die klaren Fakten
will ein weiteres Beispiel ansprechen
nämlich das Thema lufteinhaltung wir
erinnern uns ja noch alle an die
fahrverbotsdebatten vor wenigen Jahren
jetzt sind die Grenzwerte eingehalten
dank der Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung
auch weil sehr viel dafür investiert
wurde dank der Anstrengung der Kommunen
und auch der betroffenen Autofahrer und
jetzt kommt die EU-Kommission mit einem
neuen Vorschlag um die Ecke Grenzwerte
massiv verschärfen da erwarte ich von
der Umwelt und
Verbraucherschutzministerin doch dass
sie sich in diese Debatte einschaltet
darauf hinweist wie viel besser die Luft
in Deutschland in den letzten Jahren
geworden ist das für eine erreicht haben
das ist doch ein Erfolg der
Umweltpolitik auf den wir gemeinsam
stolz sein können hier geht's auch um
die Glaubwürdigkeit der Politik in
Deutschland und Europa wenn jetzt
einfach neue Grenzwerte kommen nachdem
die Grenzwerte erreicht sind neue
Belastung für Kommunen und Autofahrer
werden die Folge
da muss ich dann auch mal in die
ampelgerichtet sagen sie haben sich in
einem Beschluss mal vorgenommen ein
belastungsmoratorium
als Maßstab für sich zu setzen und zwar
vor allem auch gerichtet nach Europa und
leider müssen wir feststellen
deutschland ist und bleibt unter grüner
Elite ungeachtet der jeweiligen
sinnhaftigkeiten Treiber für strenger
Grenzwerte für höhere Auflagen mehr
Bürokratie für ausrufende Kosten das
sehen wir beide Luftreinhaltung das
werden wir zu fünftig beim
Pflanzenschutz sehen und das konnten wir
bei den CO2 flottengrenzwerten schon
eindrucksvoll miterleben die FDP bemüht
sich redlich aber beim verbrennerverbot
was dann nur eine relativ unverbindliche
protokollene Notiz ich halte das alles
meine Damen und Herren
verbranntgefährlich denn wenn Mobilität
Energieversorgung industrielle
Produktion oder landwirtschaftliche
Erzeugung sich nicht mehr in Europa
rechnen dann schwindet auch die
Akzeptanz des Umweltschutzes eine
weltweite Vorreiterrolle durch
Technologie und Innovation das sollte
Deutschlands Anspruch sein das
Bundesumweltministerium darf hier nicht
weiter der Bremse sein
und für die Bundesregierung erteile ich
das Wort dem parlamentarischen
Staatssekretär Christian kühn
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin vertik
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nur selten in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
waren Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher so sehr
auf ein handlungsfähigen Staat
angewiesen wie in diesen Krisenzeiten
wir als bundesumwelt und
Verbraucherschutzministerium als
Bundesregierung in der Gänze als
Ampelkoalition haben umfangreiche
Maßnahmen und Hilfen auf diesen Weg
gebracht um wirklich jeden Menschen
unsere Gesellschaft gut durch diesen
Winter zu bringen wir stellen einmal die
Energieversorgung im Land für diesen
Winter sichern wir führen Preis Bremsen
ein bei Gas und Strom wir haben einen
besseren Schutz vor Kündigungen bei
energieverträgen bereits gesetzlich
umgesetzt wir sorgen dafür dass niemand
den Strom oder das Gas abgestellt
bekommt wenn er die Rechnung nicht
bezahlen kann und da werden wir diese
Woche noch im Kabinett dazu Regelungen
auf den Weg bringen
wir haben wie in dieser Debatte auch
schon gesagt worden ist massiv die
Mittel bei der Schuldnerberatung erhöht
was der Bund leisten kann im Rahmen des
sozusagen des Grundgesetzes und ich
möchte mich an dieser Stelle bei den
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeitern in den
Schuldnerberatungsstellen in Deutschland
denn wirklich bedanken in diesen Tagen
weil sie leisten einen unfassbaren
Beitrag dafür dass Menschen eben nicht
in die Verschuldung rutschen
und all diese Maßnahmen all diese
Maßnahmen werden dafür sorgen dass wir
die Auswirkungen der Inflation und der
Energiepreissteigerung und der
Energiekrise auf die stärksten
betroffenen Menschen abfedern in diesen
Tagen ist eine gute
Verbraucherschutzpolitik Sozialpolitik
und wir setzen sie um meine Damen und
Herren
und klar in diesen Tagen beschäftigen
wir uns viel mit der Energieversorgung
aber wir sollten in diesen Tagen auch
nicht die langfristigen Krisen aus dem
Blick verlieren die Klimakrise des
Artensterben die verschmutzungskrise
unserer Umwelt mit Chemikalien und
Plastik und letzte Woche war die Welt
Klimakonferenz und ich will der einen
Punkt herausgreifen der auch bei diesen
Verhandlungen an immense Rolle gespielt
hat die Folgen des Klimawandels sind
längst in unserem Land massiv angekommen
global verheerende Auswirkungen aber
auch bei uns massive Auswirkungen dieser
Sommer war ein Sommer der Waldbrände der
Dürre und der Hochwasserkatastrophen und
ich will ihnen eins sagen wir werden mit
diesem Haushalt dafür sorgen dass 60
Millionen Euro verankert sind für die
Abfederung dieser folgen wir werden in
dieser Wahlperiode ein Gesetz zur
Klimaanpassung auf den Weg bringen eine
klimaanpassungsstrategie und damit
sorgen wir vor für ein gutes morgen in
diesem Land die klim Anpassung ist in
diesem Haushalt verankert und eine der
Kernaufgaben unseres Hauses in diesen
Tagen
und wir werden hier nachlegen müssen und
da werden wir gemeinsam auch an die
Union gerichtet gemeinsam dafür sorgen
müssen dass wir mehr Geld auch in
Zukunft für die Anpassung in Deutschland
auf den Weg bringen und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Umweltschutzpolitik ist oft das
Aufräumen und des reparieren dessen was
andere hinterlassen haben in ihrer Zeit
auch in der Bundesregierung und das gilt
nicht nur bei den Klimafolgen sondern
eben auch bei den Munition seitlasten
100 Millionen Euro nun um die
munitionsenlasten in Nord- und Ostsee zu
bergen danke dafür an die
Berichterstatter wirklich für ihre
Arbeit in den letzten Wochen und es gilt
eben auch bei der nuklearen Sicherheit
etwa die Hälfte des Haushalt des
Bundesumweltministeriums wird dafür
eingesetzt nach dem Atomausstieg die
zwischen und Endlagerung des
radioaktivenös zu gewährleisten die
Hälfte dieses Haushaltes und angesichts
dieser Dimension bin ich froh dass wir
am Atomausstieg zum 15 April nächsten
Jahres festhalten und keinen
zusätzlichen Müll in Deutschland
produzieren es ist gut es ist gut dass
diese Bundesregierung am Atomausstieg
deswegen auch festhält diese
Bundesregierung klammert sich nicht wie
andere im Haus an der Vergangenheit soll
wir sind in die Zukunft gerichtet der
Einzelplan 16 trägt dazu massiv bei die
Krisen der Zukunft zu bewältigen ich
bedanke mich nochmal an allen
Beteiligten bei den Haushaltsberatungen
für ja die konstruktiven Gespräche für
die Arbeit der berichterstatterinnen und
bitte um Zustimmung zum Haushalt danke
schön
sagt der Parlamentarische Staatssekretär
Christian kühn hier zu diesem Einzelplan
ja es bleibt eine Atome Aufstieg auch
wenn der Bundestag ja am 11 November
erst die Laufzeitverlängerung der drei
letzten deutschen Atomkraftwerke
beschlossen hat die bis maximal Mitte
April 2023 laufen dürfen
werte Frau Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Umwelt und Naturschutz sind
zunehmend in Gefahr und das nicht trotz
sondern wegen der Grünen alle grünen
Minister betrachten sich vor allem als
klimaschutzminister und das ist nicht
die Lösung das ist das Problem irgendwie
erinnert das alles an den Titel des
Bestsellers von Richard David Precht wer
bin ich und wenn ja wie viele es könnte
lustig sein wenn es nicht so traurig
wäre denn wenn ich weiß wer er
eigentlich ist und was er eigentlich zu
tun hat ist als Minister ungeeignet mit
der Einstufung des Ausbaus von
Windkraftanlagen als öffentliches
Interesse hat sich die Bundesregierung
einseitig zugunsten des Klimaschutzes
und zulasten des Artenschutzes
positioniert mehrere und Wälder werden
zunehmend auf den Atem werden zunehmend
zu Industriegebieten
reduziert und die Auswirkungen auf den
artenschutzwerden verheerend sein
bereits jetzt sterben jährlich
hunderttausende Vögel und Fledermäuse an
Windkraftanlagen und die Auswirkungen
auf Insekten sind noch nicht einmal
erforscht zwar verweist die
Bundesregierung Einzelplan 16 auf
gestiegene Mittel für den Artenschutz
aber das Mehr an Mittel für den
Artenschutz kann ja das weniger an Arten
nutzen keine Art und Weise kompensieren
das osterpaket der Bundesregierung war
der größte politische Anschlag auf den
Artenschutz seit Gründung des Umwelt und
des Umweltministeriums und die Grünen
tragen dafür maßgeblich die
Verantwortung beim Klimaschutz setzt die
Bundesregierung hingegen auf die
dekarbonisierung der Sektoren
stromverkehr und Wärme beim Strom hält
sie lieber an der co2-reichen
Kohleverstromung fest und eben nicht an
der CO2-armen Kernenergie beim Verkehr
bremst sie synthetische Kraftstoffe aus
obwohl sich damit ab 2035 nicht nur die
neu sondern auch die bestandsflotte CO2
neutral betreiben ließe diese Politik
ist widersprüchlich und mehr noch diese
Politik ist sogar gemeingefährlich denn
der Präsident des Bundesamtes für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
warnt vor Stromausfällen ich frage die
Bundesregierung muss Deutschland erst
das Licht ausgehen damit Ihnen das Licht
in der Regierung endlich aufgeht
doch Deutschland irrlichstadt weiter
dies wurde auch beim weltklima-gipfel in
Ägypten deutlich die Vertragsstaaten
lehnten eine Verschärfung der
Klimaschutzpolitik aufgrund der
wirtschaftlichen Krise ab nicht jedoch
Deutschland Politiker in Deutschland
Speisen die Bürger lieber mit
Energiespartipps wie nutzt Waschlappen
oder trag zwei Pullover ab es lässt sich
gut reden wenn Politiker in Ägypten bei
Temperaturen um 27 Grad getreu dem Motto
außer Spesen nichts gewesen ihre Zeit
verbringen während sich Bürger in
Deutschland überleben müssen ob sie
lieber essen oder heizen sollen mit
dieser Arroganz und Ignoranz gegen den
gegenüber den Bürgern muss endlich
Schluss sein und zum Schluss werter Herr
Staatssekretär kühn sie haben völlig zu
Recht die Rolle der Schuldnerberatung
herausgestellt schaut man sich diesen
Haushalt an sollte die Bundesregierung
als größter Schuldner selber
Schuldnerberatung annehmen vielen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
der Kollege Carsten Träger
lukastenträger ist ob man im Ausschuss
für Umwelt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen so eine
Haushaltsdebatte ist immer eine
Gelegenheit für einen kurzen Blick
zurück und dann für einen Blick auch
voraus und wenn wir auf die Ergebnisse
des Klimagipfels in Scharmbeck Shake
schauen da müssen wir feststellen dass
da viele Deutungen möglich sind ein
Gipfel in extrem schwierigen Zeiten
Ukraine Krieg Energiekrise generell
sozusagen die Haltung vieler Nationen in
solchen Situationen zurück ins fossile
Zeitalter sich zu bewegen
dass die ärmeren Staaten die am
stärksten vom Klimawandel betroffen sind
und gleichzeitig am wenigsten dazu
beitragen dass sie jetzt mit einem
ausgleichsforst unterstützt werden das
ist eine gute Sache und ein toller
Erfolg von Svenja Schulze und vom
Verhandlungsteam der ganzen
Bundesregierung aber dass wir das Klima
waren die Ergebnisse
ausbaufähig und damit auch die
Ergebnisse für die Biodiversität denn
die beiden großen Krisen die Klimakrise
und die biodiversitätskrise das sind
zwei Seiten der gleichen Medaille sie
bedingen sich gegenseitig und sie lassen
sich auch nur gemeinsam lösen das heißt
für uns wir müssen jetzt ran klotzen wir
müssen für gute Ergebnisse bei dem
universitätskonferenz im moreal in
diesem Dezember
mit dem Haushalt
unterstreichen wir an dieser Stelle die
große Bedeutung des natürlichen
Klimaschutzes vier Milliarden stehen in
den nächsten Jahren für das
Aktionsprogramm natürlicher Klimaschutz
zur Verfügung für Projekte an der
Schnittstelle Klimaschutz Klimaanpassung
und Naturschutz
hochflexibel und das ist ein großer
Schluck aus der Pulle das ist weit mehr
als wir als Naturschützer in den letzten
Jahren gewohnt waren mit dem neuen
artenhilfsprogramm erteile ich ihre
Auffassung überhaupt nicht die ist neue
Arten Hilfsprogramm unterstützt sowohl
mit Steuermitteln aber auch mit aus
Einnahmen aus der Windenergie den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien besonders die
vom Windkraft betroffenen Arten die
Mittel für den klimaanpassungen sind
aufgestockt ich glaube das sind alles
gute Nachrichten für den Natur und
Artenschutz und gleichzeitig für den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
unser positiv ich habe die Bilanz in
diesem Bereich Ziel so muss ich schon
auch sagen an dieser Stelle dass ich mir
Sorgen mache um den Verbraucherschutz
die Bevölkerung ist bis weit in den
Mittelstand hinein verunsichert und
zurecht wie ich finde die Energiekrise
die gestiegenen Preise der Inflation
sorgen dafür dass sich viele Menschen
Sorgen machen ob sie sich Energie
leisten können und ob sie überhaupt mit
dem Heizen gut über den Winter kommen
und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt an
dieser Stelle und erfordere ich uns
schon gemeinsam auf dass wir
Verbraucherschutz aus einem Guss
betreiben und dass wir vor allem auch
eine gute Kommunikation dazu machen die
nicht nur gut gemeint ist sondern auch
gut gemacht ist und das ist eine Aufgabe
der wir uns alle stellen müssen die
Mieter müssen wissen was kommt auf sie
zu die Vermieter müssen wissen was kommt
auf sie zu man muss auch mal wissen was
ist überhaupt eine gaspreisbremse und
wie funktioniert und wir wirklich
Strompreis Bremse erst dann werden sich
die Menschen in dem Land sicher sein
können dass all die guten Maßnahmen die
wir auf den Weg gebracht haben mit einem
Entlastungspaket des fast drei
entlastungspakete das fast 100
Milliarden Umfang hat und mit einer
gaspreisbremse und einem Abwehrschirm
für in der Höhe von 200 Milliarden dass
diese Maßnahmen am Ende auch bei Ihnen
ankommen das heißt wir müssen Gutes tun
da sind wir auf einem guten Weg aber wir
müssen auch gut darüber reden und das
ist nicht zuletzt die Aufgabe von uns
Verbraucherschützern
und weil ich noch ein paar Sekunden Zeit
habe ein kleines Beispiel dafür wie man
es vielleicht machen kann ein Blick über
die Grenzen nach Frankreich zu unseren
Nachbarn zeigt dass dort mit dem
Wetterbericht eine Verbraucher
stromverbrauchsampel angezeigt wird da
er steht dann rot für hohen
Energieverbrauch das hat was mit der
Energie und der Wärme zu tun die sich da
entfaltet und aber Spaß beiseite und
grün dann eben für niedrige
Energieverbrauch und man muss es ja
nicht so machen aber das sind einfache
Ideen die glaube ich den der Bedeutung
des Themas gerecht werden wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die Botschaften die
wir mit guten Grund senden dass diese
Botschaften auch bei den Menschen
ankommen wenn wir wollen dass eine
Verunsicherung die allen halben
festzustellen ist dass die nicht weiter
um sich greift sondern dass wir sagen
können Politik kümmert sich um eure
Probleme und Politik löst diese Probleme
in diesem Sinne
und für die FDP-Fraktion erteile ich das
Wort der Kollegin Judith gudelny
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen für die FDP ist
ein ausgeglichener Kernhaushalt
essentiell für eine funktionierende
Familie würde ich schon sagen für eine
funktionierende Regierung und deswegen
freue ich mich sehr dass trotz der
vielfältigen Herausforderung genau der
Kernhaushalt ausgeglichen ist und
trotzdem haben wir es als
Umweltpolitiker geschafft im Vergleich
zum Jahr 2022
280 Millionen Euro mehr auszugeben im
Bereich Umwelt und Verbraucherschutz und
in den berichterstatte Gesprächen noch
mal eine Schippe vorne draufzulegen das
zeigt die neue Schwerpunktsetzung in
dieser Ampelkoalition und es zeigt das
Ökonomie und Ökologie sich durchaus
miteinander vertragen
ich möchte an der Stelle natürlich auch
auf den Meeresschutz bringen weil das
eine ganz große Herausforderung war die
wir endlich angegangen sind und ich
möchte einmal erklären warum wir jetzt
30 Millionen und erst später noch mal
weitere 72 Millionen in die Hand nehmen
wir sehen das Korrosionsschäden auf also
auftreten jetzt schon aber was wir im
Moment nur beseitigen können sind die
Munition lassen die gerade in
schiffswegen sind das ökologisch ein
Desaster passiert und das durch die
Kontinent durch die Vergiftung der
meeressor machen es einfach durch die
Vergiftung der Meere auch Menschen
gefährdet werden wurde in den letzten
Jahren
ignoriert in diesem Jahr gehen wir es an
wir planen die richtige Entsorgung und
dabei werden wir Hightech einsetzen wir
werden ferngesteuerte Roboter an den
Boden setzen und wir werden eine
schwimmende Plattform in Auftrag geben
dass wir auf den Meeren die Bergung und
Entsorgung schadstofffrei gewährleisten
können weil viel davon genau weil sie
davon aber überhaupt erstmal entwickelt
werden muss nutzt es nicht ganz viel
Geld in diesem Jahr auszugeben wir
müssen perspektivisch einen Marathon
laufen und deswegen 30 Millionen in
diesem Jahr 70 in den kommenden vier
dann sind unsere Meeren von unseren
munitionsatlasten aus zwei Weltkriegen
endlich wieder sauber
im Verbraucherschutz im
Verbraucherschutz müssen wir auch viel
tun die steigenden Energiepreise und die
Investition
für dazu dass die Menschen in
Deutschland bis in die Mittelschicht
hinein schwer belastet sind und gerade
diejenigen die jeden Tag darum kämpfen
ihre Einnahmen und Ausgaben ausgeglichen
zu halten haben wir mit mehreren
entlastungspaketen geholfen allerdings
wird es weiterhin diejenigen geben die
vielleicht trotzdem durch zusätzliche
Herausforderungen den neuen also die
neuen finanziellen Belastungen nicht
stemmen können und eigentlich wissen wir
auch dass das Ländersache ist und hier
die Hilfe zu leisten weil aber die
Länder eigene Herausforderungen haben
haben wir in diesem Haushalt 4 Millionen
Euro um die Hand genommen um die
Resilienz überschuldete Haushalte zu
stärken damit wir eben erreichen das auf
Augenhöhe Strom und Gas sparen vermieden
werden wir haben es im Entlastungspaket
versprochen diese Regierung wird liefern
auch in der Krise wird es in Deutschland
keine Strom und Gasper geben
die größten finanziellen Risiken und
Chancen liegen aber nicht tatsächlich im
umwelthaushalt sie liegen in
begleitenden Haushalten und da möchte
ich zunächst mal mit dem größten Risiko
anfangen wir haben in den letzten Jahren
gehört dass die Endlagersuche doppelt so
lange mindestens doppelt so lange dauern
wird wie im Moment wie ursprünglich
prognostiziert finanziert wird das Ganze
aus dem Kennwort aus dem Fond für
kenn-technische Entsorgung und das
Problem dieses Fonds was das in den
letzten Jahren die Zinsentwicklung nicht
ganz so gut waren wie wir ursprünglich
gehofft haben im Moment gar kein Problem
wenn aber die Endlagersuche doppelt so
lange dauert dann wissen wir schon dass
hinten raus die Finanzierung schwierig
wird und weil wir den nachfolgenden
Generationen nicht nur die
Herausforderung der Endlagersuche mit
auf den Weg geben werden sondern
gleichzeitig die Mittel nämlich die
finanziellen Mittel das auch zu
erreichen mit auf den Weg geben müssen
wir uns schon heute darüber Gedanken
machen eine Aufgabe die sich diese
Bundesregierung annehmen wird
nein
die größten Möglichkeiten die diese
Bundesregierung hat liegen im Klima und
Transformation vor wir werden in den
nächsten vier Jahren vier Milliarden
Euro für Klima und Umweltschutz in
Deutschland ausgeben können wir werden
natürlichen Klimaschutz Resilienz vor
Hochwasser wir werden Artenschutz alles
unter einen Hut bringen die ersten
Schritte sind wir mit der nationalen
moschusstrategie schon gegangen wir
werden die Kommunen stärken das ist der
nächste Schritt und Anfang März werden
wir ein umfassendes Maßnahmenpaket im
fast trackverfahren vorlegen ich freue
mich darauf mit der Ampel und mit der
Bundesregierung insbesondere mit
Ministerin Lemke diese 4 Milliarden sind
voll in Klima und Umweltschutz für
Deutschland umzusetzen eine Aufgabe die
wir uns allen angenommen haben und die
auf die sich eigentlich das ganze Haus
freuen sollte
wir sehen dass wir eine neue
Schwerpunktsetzung haben wir schaffen es
Wirtschaft und Umwelt unter einen Hut zu
bringen ein Ding des ohne die Ampel
nicht möglich gewesen wäre und deswegen
bedanke ich mich nicht nur an den
Haushalt und sondern auch an meine
berichterstatte dass wir diese Leistung
hier geschafft haben
und für die CDU CSU hat das Wort die
Kollegin Anja Karliczek
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich will noch
mal den Fokus auf etwas anderes lenken
als über Verbraucherschutz haben schon
so viele drüber gesprochen und ich will
nur drei Punkte ansprechen die mir
persönlich aber auch unserer Fraktion
wichtig sind das erste ist mikroplastik
in den Flüssen und Meeren ist ein großes
Problem für den Erhalt unserer
natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen und deshalb
war es uns als CDU CSU-Fraktion schon
immer einen Anliegen mit deutschem
Know-how und deutscher Technologie
mitzuhelfen dieses Problem weltweit in
den Griff zu kriegen und deutsche
Unternehmerinnen sind hier führend und
wegweisend und wenn sie ihr Können in
die Welt exportieren sollen dann müssen
wir sie genau an dieser Stelle
unterstützen und genau aus diesem Grund
haben wir schon zu den
Haushaltsberatungen 22 also ein gutes
Jahr vorher ein Änderungsantrag
formuliert den Export von
Umwelttechnologien mit 25 statt 17
Millionen zu unterstützen das war für
die Ampel ganz schnell aber ich freue
mich sehr und will an dieser Stelle auch
Danke sagen dass sie nun mit einjähriger
Verspätung unserem Anliegen folgen
ein zweiter Punkt der mich persönlich
auch bei mir im Wahlkreis sehr bewegt
hat die Änderungen des
bundes-emissionsschutzgesetzes haben
einfach zu lange gebraucht wenn
vorausschauende Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer nicht schon im Frühjahr
begonnen hätten Alternativen für ihre
bisherige Energieversorgung aufzubauen
dann würde die Änderung die wir jetzt
nach den Sommerferien auf den Weg
gebracht haben ins Leere laufen sie
haben Gott sei Dank spät und zwar mit
unserer Unterstützung sie haben in dem
in der Anhörung alle dagegen rotiert und
alles mögliche dagegen ins Feld gebracht
wir waren die einzigen die es
unterstützt haben sehr spät aber dann
haben sie doch die Erleichterungen fürs
bundesmissionsschutzgesetz auf den Weg
gebracht und das war für viele
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
große Sorgen gehabt haben eine große
Erleichterung die wir sehr begrüßen
und drittens möchte ich Ihnen noch eins
mit auf den Weg geben kümmern Sie sich
frühzeitig um die
industrie-emissionsschutzrichtlinie die
gerade aus Brüssel kommt es kann noch
nicht sein dass wir gerade Unternehmen
helfen ihre Geschäftsmodelle durch Gas
und strompreisbremse zu retten beim
bundes-emissionsschutzgesetz in viel
Switch erleichtern und gleichzeitig mit
einer verschärften
industriemissionsrichtlinie aus Brüssel
konfrontiert werden wo sind denn
eigentlich die Verhandler der deutschen
Bundesregierung sagen die gar nichts
mehr dazu ich kann das Wort
belastungsmotorium gerne auch noch mal
buchstabieren vielleicht hilft das das
Industrieland Deutschland steht unter
massivem Druck bitte sorgen Sie dafür
dass nicht jetzt noch weitere
Verschärfung und Auflagen auf uns einen
Presse es ist eine falsche Maßnahme zur
falschen Zeit denn viele Unternehmen
sind guten Willens und auf einem guten
Weg sie wollen ihre Geschäftsmodelle
Team Modelle klimaschonend und Klima
neutral machen und dazu brauchen sie
gerade nicht
in der Regel aus Brüssel und Berlin
sondern Beinfreiheit den eigenen
für die cdu/csu-fraktion und es folgt
jetzt hier in der Aussprache zum
Einzelplan
Linda Heitmann für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen
ist die Obfrau im Umweltausschuss frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren in
dieser Beratung des
bmuv-haushaltes möchte ich jetzt doch
gern noch mal das V im Namen besonders
stark machen und den Blick auf den
Verbraucherschutz hier lenken wir haben
in diesem Haushalt wie im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart noch einmal
den vzbv gestärkt und damit wirklich die
starke Vertretung von
Verbraucherinteressen in Deutschland ich
finde das sollten wir auch noch mal in
diesem Haushalt herausstellen und wir
müssen darauf gucken manche
Verbrauchergruppen brauchen diese
Stärkung und diese Unterstützung aber
ganz besonders es wurde jetzt schon
mehrfach darauf eingegangen dass wir die
Mittel gerade im Bereich der
Schuldnerberatung gegenüber dem Vorjahr
verdoppelt haben
es reicht ihnen vielleicht nicht aber
wir arbeiten daran dass diese Mittel und
der Bund kann nur begrenzt Mittel auch
in die Schuldnerberatung stecken da sind
auch die Länder in der Pflicht das
aufzustocken aber wir
aber wir arbeiten daran dass dieses Geld
wirklich auch dahin fließt wo es ganz
besonders gebraucht wird dass
beispielsweise aufsuchende
Schuldnerberatung stattfindet für
Menschen die mobilitätseingeschränkt
sind dass das vielleicht auch mehr
sprachlich geschieht diese
Schuldnerberatung damit wirklich jene
von diesem Geldern auch profitieren die
das ganz besonders nötig haben in diesem
Land
und nicht zuletzt haben wir jetzt auch
die Konzeptentwicklung eines
Bundesinstituts für Verbraucherforschung
hier im Haushalt mit drin damit wir
künftig noch zielgenauer wissen wie
effiziente Verbraucherpolitik wirklich
gut Wirkung entfalten kann
aber ich möchte auch noch mal darauf
eingehen dass gerade im Bereich
Verbraucherschutz gar nicht immer alles
unbedingt so viel Geld kosten muss wir
beraten hier in den kommenden Monaten
das Verbandsklagerecht und wollen das
auf den Weg bringen und das gilt es
wirklich gut und klug auszugestalten
damit wir auch an dieser Stelle die
Verbraucher Interessen wirklich gut
stärken können wir haben in diesem
Koalitionsvertrag noch andere Projekte
wie die bestätigungslösung von
telefonisch geschlossenen Verträgen oder
bessere Transparenz bei kreditoring und
nicht zuletzt wollen wir auch noch
vernünftige Regelungen gegen
Greenwashing auf den Weg bringen damit
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher mit
Begriffen wie Klima oder CO2 Neutralität
nicht länger hinter das Licht geführt
werden
meine Damen und Herren wenn wir all das
sowohl das was hier viel Geld kostet
aber auch das was weniger Geld kostet in
2023 wirklich mit Ehrgeiz und im Sinne
der Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher in
diesem Land angehen dann glaube ich
können wir den Verbraucherschutz in
diesem Land auch auf eine neue Stufe
heben mit diesem Ministerium machen wir
das herzlichen Dank
sagt Linda Heitmann für die Grünen ja
das Ministerium heißt ja auch Umwelt
Naturschutz nukleare Sicherheit und
Verbraucherschutz der Verbraucherschutz
ja von der Justiz in dieser Legislatur
sozusagen rübergewandert in dieses
Restaurant
für die SPD meine Damen und Herren ich
lade Sie zu einem kleinen
Gedankenexperiment ein es ist nicht
völlig neu trotzdem ist es leider nach
wie vor aktuell auch wenn der Eine oder
die Andere hier im Saal ist
möglicherweise kennt es geht
folgendermaßen stellen Sie sich vor Sie
sitzen in einem handelsüblichen PKW
vielleicht in den eigenen sie fahren
über die Autobahn 100 km pro Stunde oder
einiges mehr je nachdem wie man es mit
dem Tempolimit hält und stellen Sie sich
nun vor der laufende Motor verliert so
nach und nach ein Schräubchen nach dem
anderen
oder sie entfernen ein Schräubchen nach
dem anderen oder ein anderes Bestandteil
das erste ist vielleicht noch völlig
harmlos es passiert nichts weiter der
Motor fährt weiter sie fühlen sich
sicher sie entfernen das zweite
Bestandteil auch das ist möglicherweise
noch unkritisch wenn sie aber dieses
Gedankenexperiment konsequent fortführen
werden sie wegen der Endlichkeit der
Bestandteile eines Motors irgendwann an
die Stelle kommen wo aus ihnen echt übel
nimmt und wenn sie es noch weiter
treiben werden sie irgendwann an eine
Stelle kommen wo der Schaden der das
Fehlen wesentlicher Bestandteil erzeugt
so groß wird dass der Motor sich
schlichtweg auf raucht es gibt einen
Totalschaden und das bei 100 Kilometer
pro Stunde auf der Autobahn ich glaube
niemand von uns würde vernünftigerweise
dieses Gedankenexperiment in die
Realität umsetzen
so weit sind wir uns glaube ich erstmal
einig trotz an das lauten dazwischenrufe
das aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ist genau die Situation bei der
sogenannten biodiversitätskrise die
eigentlich der Pfad hin ist zu einem
erneuten Massenaussterben so brutal muss
man es sagen denn wir reden über
Ökosysteme bei dem die Arten Pflanzen
und Tiere eng miteinander verknüpft sind
und wir nicht einfach einzelne entnehmen
oder unfreiwillig aussterben lassen
können ohne den Kollaps des gesamten
Ökosystems des betreffenden Ökosystems
zu riskieren das ist unsere Situation
meine Damen und Herren
ein paar Zahlen 50 Prozent aller
lebenden Korallen sind bisher
verschwunden in Deutschland 75 Prozent
der Biomasse Insekten bei den großen
Säure Säugetieren sind ca 3 sind ca 3/4
aus ihren traditionellen Lebensräumen
verschwunden täglich sterben so die
Schätzung 150 Pflanzen und Tierarten und
wiederbringlich aus wir werden sie nicht
zurückholen soweit die Fakten das heißt
wir sind auf dem Pfad in ein sechstes
diesmal menschengemachtes
Massenaussterben und wir müssen vieles
dagegen tun die Gründe vielleicht auch
dazu noch zwei Sätze anders als es hier
Anklagen natürlich ist der
menschengemachte Klimawandel einer der
haupttreiber es ist aber bei weitem
nicht der einzige auch die Zerstörung
der Lebensräume für die Nutzung durch
Landwirtschaft oder anderes die
Umweltverschmutzung mikroplastik ist
schon genannt worden Ölkatastrophen und
illegale ungeregelte Abfallentsorgung
sind weitere Ursachen
dieses drohende Massensterben ist also
eine eigenständige Katastrophe die
abzugrenzen ist von der Klimakatastrophe
auch wenn es zahlreiche Verbindungen
gibt ich habe versucht das zu skizzieren
warum muss uns das interessieren anders
als es hier bei einigen Beiträgen aus
der Union Anklang wird die Lösung für
zum Beispiel die Ernährungssicherheit
nicht die Züchtung neuer Arten in
Anpassung an den Klimawandel sein das
wird partiell vielleicht auch wichtig
aber es ist wichtig die bioleistung die
die Wirtschaftsleistung der Ökosysteme
aufrecht zu erhalten die Ökosysteme zu
schützen zu schützen und damit
Artenschutz zu betreiben die Ampel macht
genau das ist einiges schon gesagt
worden ich will es aber noch einmal
verstärken wichtig ist nämlich am Ende
nicht was auf dem Papier steht sondern
wichtig ist was in der Praxis ankommt
was umgesetzt wird es ist also
beispielsweise beim bundesnaturschutz
vor extrem wichtig dass die
Umsetzbarkeit gewährleistet ist das war
in der Vergangenheit kein Problem die
verschiedenen Programme zusammenzufassen
und damit Gelder auch verschieben zu
können wenn bestimmte Programme besser
laufen ist wichtig ganz entscheidend die
Absenkung des zehn prozentanteils auf
den zehn Prozentanteil die Eigenanteile
waren in der Vergangenheit in den
Kommunen immer ein Problem Programme
aufsetzen zu können Projekte aufsetzen
und umsetzen zu können das heißt wir
stocken nicht nur auf sondern wir machen
die ganze Sache auch umsetzbar ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich dass uns das gelingt
mit dem Aktionsprogramm natürlicher
Klimaschutz vier Milliarden in vier
Jahren aus dem KTF das ist ein wirklich
gutes Signal und weitere 100 Millionen
jährlich der Kollege Krebs hat sie
angedeutet ist ein richtig großer Schub
international
international liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wird sehr genau geschaut was
ihr tut was wir tun es wird nicht nur
geschaut was wir auf internationalen
Konferenzen tun sondern es wird auch
geschaut was wir bei uns tun und dieser
Haushalt dieser Einzelplan ist ein gutes
Signal und ich hoffe auf eine gelungene
Umsetzung vielen Dank
gut vielen Dank war das für die SPD und
jetzt hören wir für die
afd-fraktion den Abgeordneten Rainer
Kraft
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Präsidentin Herr
Staatssekretär Werte Kollegen es ist
heute schon angesprochen worden die
moschusstrategie der neueste Streich
also wir reden halt einfach darüber 148
Millionen Euro so viel soll die
nationale die Bürger dieses Jahr kosten
für ihre ganzen Schattenhaushalte sogar
eine relativ kleine Summe der noch ein
exzellentes Beispiel für diesen
Bundeshaushalt der viel Allokationen
gestern veröffentlichtet die Welt ein
Artikel über die Pläne des
Umweltministeriums soeben dieser
moscheenstrategie ein großer Teil der in
Jahrhunderten mühevoll in
Kulturlandschaften verwandelten
ehemaligen sumpfflächen soll wieder
verlässt werden es geht dabei um fast
18.000 Quadratkilometer an Flächen das
entspricht fast der große Sachsens und
die veranstalten Kosten bis 20 30 sollen
rund 4 Milliarden Euro sein
genau dort wo die Grünen Minister für
Umwelt und der Landwirtschaft wieder
frühzeitliche Sümpfe und Moore bilden
wollen werden heute nachwachsende
Rohstoffe und dringend benötigte
Lebensmittel erzeugt offensichtlich sind
sie aber der Meinung dass man darauf
verzichten kann das geht heute dem Motto
der Strom kommt aus der Steckdose und
der Kartoffeln vom Bio-Supermarkt
wir reden nicht über existierende Sumpfe
und Moorflächen der Schutz dieser
Ökosysteme steht außer Frage die
Diskussion dreht sich um Fläche die
ehemalsund oder Moa war aber heute Teil
der Kulturlandschaft ist die Liebe für
nachweiszeitliche Moore und
Sumpflandschaften entspricht dabei nicht
dem Umwelt oder Artenschutz genannten
nein es ist wie so oft bei Ihnen die CO2
Ideologie 5 Millionen Tonnen CO2 sollen
so nach dem Willen bis 20 30 durch ihre
Muschel Strategie jährlich eingespart
werden zum Vergleich die Volksrepublik
China braucht derzeit drei Stunden und
49 Minuten um diese Einsparung wieder
zunichte zu machen also 4 Milliarden an
Steuergeldern verpulver und verschwendet
für die Ablösung von 3 Stunden und 49
Minuten an CO2 Emission das ist komplett
liebes Umweltministerium
genauso absurd geht es weiter auf Seite
19 des moorschutzpapieres dort wird
behauptet dass der Schutz der Moore
einen signifikanten Beitrag unter
anderem zu erreichen des
nachhaltigkeitsziels Nummer zwei die
Bekämpfung des globalen Hungers sei und
natürlich gefreut mit dem Ministerin da
ist sie ist leider erkrankt aber
vielleicht kannst Du mir der
staatsregitär ja erklären wie kann wie
kann das absaufen lassen von 340.000
Hektar wertvolle Ackerfläche und 930.000
Flächen an Weide und Grünflächen einen
wertvollen Beitrag zur Bekämpfung der
globalen Ernährungskrise bilden wer kann
mir das erklären
das Gegenteil ist doch der Fall die
Reduzierung der Nahrungsmittelproduktion
im Inland führt seinen verstärkten
Ankauf auf dem Weltmarkt von
Lebensmitteln und am Ende dieses
bedrängungswettbewerbes in den
herbstländern der Welt werden die Erbsen
Leute ohne Nahrung darstellen
am Ende heißt das sie verschwenden 4
Milliarden Euro an Steuergeldern und
verschärfen damit in den ersten Ländern
der Welt die Ernährungskrise dann dann
werden diese Menschen von ihnen wieder
als Opfer der Klimaveränderung
instrumentalisiert werden Sie uns
erzählen was für diesen Leuten wieder
ein Unrecht getan haben tatsächlich aber
sind diese Menschen das Opfer ihrer
Misswirtschaft und ihrer sogenannten
Klimapolitik
[Applaus]
reiner Kraft war das für die
afd-fraktion ja und trotz seiner Kritik
und auch der Kritik aus den anderen
Oppositionsfraktionen wird auch dieser
Einzelplan heute in zweiter Lesung
mutmaßlich mit den Stimmen der
Ampelkoalition hier verabschiedet werden
wollen werden wir sind in der
haushaltswoche und das war sozusagen das
letzte Wort zu jetzt zum ersten Tag der
Haushaltsberatung seit heute morgen um
10 Uhr sind wir live für Sie dabei
gewesen und ich darf sie noch ein
bisschen einstimmen auf morgen da steht
nämlich an der Schlagabtausch hier im
Deutschen Bundestag die sogenannte
Generaldebatte und ab 8:45 Uhr sind wir
dann wieder hier bei Phoenix live für
Sie dabei für heute darf ich mich von
ihnen verabschieden und gebe direkt nach
Bonn zu Meyer Weber